foreign
I want to ask you about fatherhood so I
have a note here
the fatherhood has been the best thing
you've ever done and as someone who does
not yet have children but someday hopes
to
could you please expand on that I'd love
to hear why that is the case
while I only have five children
uh you got some work to do to catch up
with Elon but exactly you're doing all
right there are others who've beat me
and I I wouldn't catch up
I'm too old to have any more
children because in the end you can have
children of
at 58 but you will not be good at soccer
when they are ready for soccer and uh
you have a moral obligation to be able
to go and kick that ball around
I have children who range in age from 28
down to five
and I can say unequivocally that they
are the best thing
that ever happened to me and the thing I
care people I care most about
and I never Tire of
watching them
grow helping them in any way I can
fatherhood for me has been
more fulfilling than I would ever have
imagined I think most people most men
let me say most men before they become
fathers
secretly dread
the loss of freedom
the regime of of diapers and the
prospect of being vomited on
and all of these things will happen when
you become a father you will be vomited
on and diapers will become a very large
an unpleasant part of your life and you
won't be able to go
out anything like
you were able to before on the other
hand
there is something far more fulfilling
about helping and an infant uh learn
than than anything is anything else
that's available to us so
I don't know that I've been a taller
a great father I think I've been okay
and the way I would think about the role
is
is yeah it's very much pedagogical I I'm
very assiduously read to my children and
get them to read and make books a big
part of of life
I think that's that's really critical
because
these days
as children grow up there are way more
distractions than there were in in my
day and you have to make a constant
concentrated effort as a parent to make
sure that they get into the habit of
reading reading books because almost all
the accumulated wisdom of our species is
in fact contained in books and some of
these books are quite old
and unlikely to be assigned in
contemporary education so that's a big
part of it then there is all the kind of
that funny business of of
teaching children to be good
what is it to be good what is it to be
kind how does one actually convey that
how can one make a child creative
without over scheduling them with
Monday's piano Tuesdays coding
Wednesdays Mandarin you know that kind
of typical parenting and I'm I'm still
you know I'm still learning I'm still
trying to get better at it
while at the same time making sure that
all all the children got the same kind
of deal
because I'm quite egalitarian about
these things and there can be no
favoritism they all must think they're
the favorite so these are the things
that if if you gave me the chance I
would talk about with
greater enthusiasm and a greater length
and
then about anything else
but you know nobody really wants to
listen to somebody else talk about their
children it's the world's most boring
subject just like you know when people
get out their phones to show you
pictures of of their children and then
they can't find them because they have
too many pictures a little part of you
dies right because it's nice
well to me at the moment this is
interesting so since since I have the
mic in front of me I'll keep I'll keep
prying when you said I'm okay and I
might be getting the exact phrasing
wrong not great why do you say that
absence because absence passive my
life's journey took me away and
continues to take me away from my
children quite a bit
there's that great moment in one of the
Austin Powers movies daddy wasn't there
do you remember that yes we all love
that Austin Powers in our family and
it's part of being a Ferguson that you
watch the Austin Powers movies much
earlier than is appropriate
but I've I've been away a lot I mean I I
was
I was so negligent as to take a job in
the United States in
2002 or thereabouts when I had three
children in school in England and my
then wife wouldn't move and I remember
saying well if I stay if I don't go I'll
I'll regret it so I'll commute
and that that was a little bit crazy and
I wouldn't advise anybody to do that I
met it meant that I was away quite a lot
it probably made the breakdown of the
marriage inevitable
so yeah you know I I think my older
children would all agree that they
didn't see enough of me and
and I've had to compensate for the those
absences by
you know trying to be
present in in other ways
so you know it's difficult I think the
truth is that if you're trying to
lead three careers as you said at the
beginning
if you're trying to do good academic
work and at the same time
engage in some kind of
public life and then also do all this
advising
sure you're gonna you're gonna work 17
hour days and you'll be in New York
and Washington and London and I used to
travel to the point of insanity prior to
the pandemic
and then the pandemic stopped that
forced me to stop and for a year I lived
in Montana and I didn't travel more than
about five miles from the house and so I
saw the two younger children every day
and it was wonderful it was wonderful my
my now 10 year old and I would go for a
walk
every day we called it the philosophical
walk and it was after he'd done with his
schoolwork and I had sort of done enough
work on my then current book and we
would just have a walk hmm I wasn't
doing that before and I'm doing it less
now so
no no I'm not gonna get great but the
test is always
are your children going to turn to you
in the moment of crisis are they going
to tell you the good news when there is
good news
are you able to remain in contact even
when there's a great distance
geographically between you
and on that basis
you know I think I get a B plus
and I and I would say to anybody who's
highly motivated super driven type A
personality
do what you have to do but remember the
relationship that you have with your
children is more important than anything
else and on your Tombstone it doesn't
say
wrote 150 emails a day or closed X deals
or it doesn't say publish 16 books
that's not what the gravestones say they
talk about whether you were a good son
whether you were a good husband and
whether you're a good father that's the
gravestone
people forget that
but that's the gravestone